after long hours at work even actors
need to blow off steam but not even
Hollywood spy mr. immune to a good weird
prank and they can get pretty strange
in honor of April Fool's Day here are
some of the most bizarre onset pranks
Chris Pratt's full Andy during a time on
Parks and Recreation Chris Pratt was
known to improvise almost constantly I
was more than 17 months with full head
of hair full head of teeth so during a
theme where his character Andy shows up
in the buff Pratt was supposed to be
wearing flesh colored undies which could
be blurred out later but since it was
April Fool's Day he thought it would be
better to just ditch the undies and just
go in his birthday suit without telling
anyone in an interview with Graham
Norton Pratt revealed the motivation for
his prank to me it didn't seem like she
really was reacting to seeing but know
what I'm gonna do apparently NBC wasn't
thrilled and he got a letter from the
network reprimanding in bridge behavior
he reacted in typical Chris Pratt
fashion he framed the letter and hung it
in his office j-law gets plugged to
death like most people Jennifer Lawrence
is terrified of bugs since Hollywood
sweetheart has pretty much no filter
when it comes to sharing things about
ourselves that fact was probably common
knowledge on the set of Hunger Games
Catching Fire so of course your co-star
Jeffrey Wright thought it would be funny
to give Lawrence a blue Tiffany box with
a surprise what was in that what about
as many crickets as I could cram into
the box Wright didn't get away without a
little bit of karmic punishment though
he went on to say it was really hard to
stuff a bunch of live crickets in a
little box so as a result he ended up
with his very own hotel room plagued
Jennifer Lawrence seems to get involved
in more onset pranks than your average
actor while shooting American hustle
Lawrence was nervous about filming in a
graveyard
so her co-stars Christian Bale and
Bradley Cooper had the prop team make a
personalized headstone but sneak into
the theme that read Jennifer Lawrence
born August 15 1890 died April 1st 1913
Lawrence reportedly screamed and said
that's my name
excusa coincidence or am I going to die
her co-stars quickly came clean and the
whole graveyard scene was cut anyhow but
making someone think about their own
fleeting mortality is always a pretty
great joke right right
fat damon during the filming of the
monuments men matt damon was especially
curious about slimming down for his role
so naturally whenever damon flew back to
New York during filming breaks George
Clooney would take all of Damon's
clothes to the wardrobe department and
have them made slightly smaller Damon
couldn't figure out why his clothes were
always too small causing him to hit the
gym even harder it wasn't until much
later that Damon figured it all out and
only after the psychological damage
begun I found out that only a few days
ago that you really disturbed you yeah
and I didn't I never said anything
because I thought I was being
professional in trying to lose weight
and I wasn't working even after all of
that Damon says he would never try to
prank the notorious prankster back
saying he doesn't want to poke the bear
when you get into a prank war with
Clooney you might not survive fishing
for Leo
after weeks of playing the victim that
Leonardo DiCaprio is roughhousing on the
set of wolf of wallstreet Jonah Hill
felt like he needed a little retribution
so during the first take of the film's
sushi scene everything when it's planned
and he'll laid everything on his place
but later Hill went off script and let
DiCaprio take the last piece you need to
love sushi okay look at all these photos
now imagine doing that 70 times he'll is
familiar with director Martin Scorsese
penchant for shooting the same scene
over and over and over by the end of the
night DiCaprio had eaten an entire
school of yellowtail for some that's a
regular knife for sushi lightweight
DiCaprio it meant puking into a trash
can of course after the scene he'll
probably had more than enough fish for
one film the Yentl of doom not even
Steven Spielberg is immune to the lure
of onset pranking during a scene in
Indiana Jones of the Temple of Doom
Harrison Ford is tied up and whipped by
a rather gigantic man during one take
rather than employing one of the bad
guys from the film
Spielberg had Barbra Streisand's show up
fully dressed in leather to do the
whipping with each lash strike Sam would
be raped forward for his movies
to top things off Carrie Fisher also
shows up the shield forward and give him
a kiss well played Spielberg starstruck
by Vigo Peter Jackson's sprawling Lord
of the Rings films are beautiful well
acted and kind of violent that could be
why Viggo Mortensen decided to start a
new tradition on set according to
multiple co-stars Mortensen headbutts
people hard it's kind of like his way of
saying hello accept the phenomenon
spread and cause more than a few
temporary blackouts on set like the one
when our Lando bloom was clobbered I was
thinking I might never see again
but I think he enjoyed it the tradition
follows through all three movies and the
red carpet and Elijah Wood called it
spontaneous violent love when you start
calling concussions love it's time to
find new friends thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love whew
[Applause]
you
[Music]